[Music]
cool okay so I'm having a feeling pick
one we go through three or four my big
idea is around intimacy and technology
and the ethics of that so what happens
when we live in a world with increasing
in mind self technology artificial
intelligence and robots okay one of the
areas I work in is sex so I look at how
people can be intimate using technology
whether that's through sex toys whether
that's through connecting to other
people online or if it's through sex
robots so sorry about about three years
ago I started working on the topic of
sex robots and I've been doing some
research
and I've written a book on it in the
last year and it's one of the things
that I talked about at the festival this
year so I look at highlight has
developed over time the whole narrative
of the sex robot going from the ancient
Greeks right through to the sci-fi
movies that we watch today and there are
two aspects of this there's the aspect
of sex toys that have been around for
millennia and then there's the sex robot
which comes from the idea of the sex
doll and I think we can do much better
than the sex doll aspects of sex robots
and I think we should be making really
interesting forms of sensuality and
intimacy out of the technology we have
we have so many interesting materials
that we can use today so we have got
fitness trackers we can read people's
brain waves we can tickle information
and feed it into smart fabrics and to
conductive paint into all kinds of
vibrating motors we can make something
really cool so perhaps you want a sex
duvet we can do that for you what is sex
to vanilla okay
what would a sexy me look like I don't
know that's just my example of where we
might go with this technology perhaps
you have a piece of responsive fabric
that wraps around you and pers or griles
perhaps you have a bad made of breasts
perhaps you have some kind of device
with interchangeable attachments that
you can use the thing is we've got all
this technology we just have to think of
different ways to piece it together
though there are lots of ethical issues
arise
sex robots that currently and they do
exist just there currently just these
sex dolls with a bit of animatronics and
a bit of AI in them and they are really
hyper sexualized pornified objective
depth right yeah they are really just
purified hyper sexualized mannequins of
women and I think that's really
dangerous to us because it increases
objectification and it's also built for
a very straight male audience so it's
not inclusive it's not laborious so why
don't we just break out of that idea of
creating humanoid robots and that goes
for really any kind of humanoid robots
let's get out of that idea we're very
rubbish at building humanoid robots so
let's build something more interesting
what do you say to people who argue that
sex is just like a natural thing that
takes place between two or more people
okay so a lot of people are concerned
that there has to be some kind of
sacredness or purity to sex and I think
I can see how sex can be a really lovely
thing between two people or more people
but masturbation is also an everyday
part of life 95% of people will probably
admit to that if you ask them and it's
and it can also be used we can use this
technology to facilitate and enhance
relationships so I'm not worried about
machines coming in to replace humans I
think it's something that we can use to
enhance their lives instead data one of
the things people are concerned about is
privacy and security and rightly so
because we've seen in the past couple of
years smart sex toys that have been
hacked so the data has been released and
it or it's it is somehow been breached
or perhaps data has been recorded and it
hasn't been stored properly and that is
dangerous and when you're dealing with
someone's sensitive data particularly
sexual data that has the potential to
ruin someone's life that has the
potential to kill in certain parts of
the world so we do have to be really
cautious fortunately there are white hat
hackers out there people who go and look
for these vulnerability
in smart connected sex toys to make sure
that that doesn't happen but nothing is
foolproof and you need to be wearing
great what's the M what's the next five
years like in technology I think in the
next five years we're going to see some
more interesting developments in sex
toys we're certainly getting reports
that more of these commercial sex robots
would be released so far it's only been
in the past month that one has been
commercially available there is talk of
bringing out a meal version as well from
the same company he made the female
version I don't think that markets gonna
go all that well I think that's a really
really niche market that's predominantly
predominantly for people with other
fetishes or people looking for the
companionship that a sex doll brings to
them now is that the risk that this kind
of like in some way some size of
Internet it's sort of inflamed like your
keyboard is there the risk that this
technology claim this makes things worse
it's nice to see a utopian vision maybe
it brings people together
yeah like helps you realize desires but
it couldn't also you know go sour
there's always a potential for
technology to go sour there's always the
potential for outliers for people to
either abuse that technology or not know
when to stop that is always going to be
there it's there with computer games for
example as well or internet porn all of
those kind of things in some ways
there's been talk recently about in cell
culture and high sex robots could be a
solution to that I don't think that's
the case I think that when you look at
the the Insull forums which i've had to
do unfortunately you find out that
they'll though they suggest this as an
alternative they're not going to stop
the misogyny just because they have some
kind of sex robot it is as they say it's
a kind of cope it's something that's
just a substitute and they're not going
to be happy with that we should
literally embrace technology perhaps I
think we need to be cautious we always
do there are cases where it's not going
to be good there's always concerns about
what happens if someone makes a
childlike version for example that's an
area that needs regulation because that
falls under a category of images of
child abuse and that kind of related
legal legality of the system
so I think we need to be cautious about
things like that but I think we are more
fearful than we should be in a lot of
aspects for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai TV
you